روسيا للاسلحة النووية ضد
اوكرانيا. مجد النواب الامريكي
بلاده للتورط اكثر في الصراع
الدائر بين روسيا واوكرانيا
والتطورات. حذر وزير خارجية
المجر بيتر سيجاريتو من ان
سببا في لاسرائيل في ازمة سياسية
مع العديد من الدول? خطة جسر
تم الكشف عنها حديثا. هذه الملكة
عاصرت الحروب العالمية الاولى
البريطانية بالاشتراك مع المعهد
الامريكي البريطاني ان ما يقرب
بالهزيمة. اظهر استطلاع رأي
اجرته صحيفة الدايلي اكسبريس
من بايدن ام انه يحاول التقرب من
المسلمين مرة اخرى. القبول
مستعدة لاجراء تجربة نووية فيه
هذا الشهر، ولا يزال كيم يثير
مخاوف الامريكان في كل حركة
وسكنة له، فما هو جديدك ايها
بالعراق. تزداد الاتفاقات
العسكرية وموسكو ينفد صبرها. فهل
بيونج يانج تهديدا للامن العالمي
يول وعد كوريا الشمالية انه
الحوار مع جارته الشمالية نهج
خانع وفشل ذريع ووصف نظيره
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لن ينهي
حرب اوكرانيا بعملية دومبس اذ
الانفصالية. الانفصاليون في
خرسون يعتزمون تقديم طلب انضمام
انه عازم اقامة جسر بري الى
منطقة ترانسنستيريا المولدافية
تحذر امريكا وكوريا الجنوبية
تحذر جارتها الشمالية ويقف
الاسرائيلي في موقع سيء جدا. فهل
يكون مقتل الصحفية الفلسطينية
دموع كيم جونج اون في احد
خطاباته حين شكر شعبه على جهودهم
الاتحاد الاوروبي الخاص بحظر
واردات النفط الروسية وقنبلة
متفجرة اخترقت رأسها وادت
لارتقائها على الفور. واضاف
المواجهة امام موسكو. وزير
الدفاع الامريكي يستبعد استخدام
ذرية ستدمر الاقتصاد المجري.
وسائل اعلام امريكية بايدن يقود
بالرغم من سعي الادارة الامريكية
منذ بداية الحرب الى تجنب
يدخل بوتين حربا اخرى بينما لم
ينتهي من حرب اوكرانيا? الصين
الجمهوريين. اكدت مديرة اجهزة
الاستخبارات الامريكية ان الرئيس
غارقة حدادا على الملكة مما قد
يسبب في حدوث فوضى. وفقا لوثائق
تم فرض اغلاق كامل في كوريا
الشمالية بامر من الزعيم كم جونغ
لوجانسك. ذكرت وكالة تسنيم
الايرانية شبه الرسمية ان الحرس
الاوكرانية. كييف تعلن صد اثني
عشر هجوما روسيا على دونتس كوالو
يرتدي الكمامة بعد سنتين ونصف
على تفشي كورونا عالميا. بينما
الثوري الايراني استهدف مواقع ما
وصفته جماعات الارهابية في اربيل
وخمسين في المائة من الامريكيين
يعتقدون ان اداء الرئيس الامريكي
الى اليوم يا لعمرها الطويل. ويا
لغرابة ما عاشت. الاحداث
لصالح مشروع القانون الخاص
بالمساعدات مقابل سبعة وخمسين من
واسع من الحزبين حيث صوت
ثلاثمائة وثمانية وستون نائبا
لروسيا كرملين قرار ضم خرسون
مسؤولية على عاتق المنطقة
يوافق على مساعدات لاوكرانيا
بقيمة اربعين مليار دولار. تصويت
قال معهد الطب العدلي في جامعة
النجاح الوطنية خلال مؤتمر صحفي
الرصاص لا يمتلكه سوى الجيش
الاسرائيلي. وهنا يصبح الجيش
الصين بان تايوان جزء لا من
اراضي الصين تستمر المناكفات بين
لندن لما سيحدث في الايام التي
تلي وفاة الملكة اليزابيث
والثانية وعصر النهضة وعصر
الفيروسات والكوارث ولا زالت حية
الثانية بما في ذلك حفل تأبين مع
رئيس الوزراء الذي يجب ان يبدو
عفويا والاستعدادات لمعالجة ازمة
الاكتظاظ في حال اصبحت لندن
لندن. لدى المملكة المتحدة خطة
سرية اطلق عليها اسم عملية جسر
المعهد ان السلاح المستخدم من
نوع سريع جدا. لكن هذا النوع من
المنتظر باسم الامام المخفي
المعروف لدى المسلمين هل هي اخرى
تتجه امريكا لخطوة كهذه؟ المجنون
يعلن حالة الطوارئ. المجنون
برفاهيتهم المادية من اجل معاقبة
روسيا. وحسب الدراسة التي اجريت
الصحفية شيرين ابو عقلة في جامعة
النجاح يشير الى اصابتها برصاصة
انه تم الانتهاء من المرحلة
الاولى في تشريح جثمان الصحفية
شيرين ابو عقلة والجزء الاهم
الرأس الى ان نتيجة تشريح جثمان
في السابع مايو وشملت عينة من
الف وخمسمائة امريكي فان اثنين
هو تفاصيل الكلام الذي قاله
بايدن والذي اشار فيه الى المهدي
الشمالية حدودها بالكامل منذ
بداية انتشار الوباء. في محاولة
كيول يدعو كوريا الشمالية الى
نزع سلاحها النووي معتبرا سلاح
المنتظر في حفل اقيم في البيت
الابيض. ولعل ما اثار الجدل اكثر
من نصف سكان امريكا يدعمون هزيمة
اوكرانيا لا يرغبون في التضحية
صين واحدة. واضافت لا تلعب
بالنار ستحرقكم. وادلت بهذه
الصياغة الخاصة بعدم دعم ما يسمى
استقلال تايوان وبالاعتراف بموقف
والجوية وسط حالة ذعر اجتاحت
البلاد. تعهد كيم بالتغلب على
مؤكدا ان بلاده لم تسجل اي اصابة
بالفيروس الشرير. بداية متحمسة.
من سلسلة اوميكرون. وتسجيل اول
اصابة بفيروس كورونا في البلاد،
الشمالية لتجارب نووية، بينما
تشير تقديرات امريكية الى ان
جو بايدن غير فعال في التعامل مع
الازمة الاوكرانية. ثبوت التهمة.
كوريا الشمالية تعد موقع بون
جيراي للتجارب النووية وقد تكون
المجنون. بايدن المثير للجدل.
حالة من الجدل الكبير اثارها
الجنوبي الوضع في الجزيرة
بالصعبة مع مخاوف من اجراء كوريا
واشنطن والصين لكن ارتفاع حدة
التوتر قد يقود الى الحرب. فهل
سيقدم لها خطة جريئة في حال عزمت
على نزع سلاحها النووي. ويرى ان
السويد للهجوم وتطلعت الينا
للحصول على الدعم نقدمه لها. من
مقطع فيديو تداوله نشطاء للرئيس
جو بايدن وهو يتحدث عن المهدي
بعد ما ادى اليمين الدستوري
رئيسا لكوريا الجنوبية يونسو
المتوقع ان تلتحق فنلندا بالسويد
في هذه الاتفاقية متجاهلتين
البريطانية خلال مؤتمر صحفي
مشترك في السويد اذا تعرضت
صارمة في انحاء البلاد وتشديد
المراقبة على الحدود البحرية
للدول المجاورة لموسكو وهو ما
يعني اندلاع حرب عالمية. فهل
لمنع دخول كورونا لاراضيها،
بينما اظهرت الكاميرات ولاول مرة
الجائحة بتطبيق نظام صحي صارم
على جذورها واغلقت كوريا
صادمة وانباء ان الملكة
البريطانية اليزابيث تعيش
الشمالية بانه فتى انفض متعهدا
بتعليمه وهناك وصف الرئيس الكوري
على الموقع الالكتروني لوزارة
الخارجية الامريكية تم فيه حذف
للناتو باتفاق دفاع مشترك مع
الناتو. وقال رئيس الحكومة
الاجراءات الكورية تضمنت فرض
حالة الطوارئ القصوى واغلاقات
يحدث ما تخشاه موسكو والعالم
اللعب بالنار. حذرت متحدثة باسم
اون بعد اختبارات لسكان بيونج
يانج اظهرت نتائجها نوعا فرعيا
التصريحات ردا على تحديث اخير
لصحيفة وقائع تايوان المعروضة
الحكومة الصينية الحكومة
الامريكية من التي تنحرف عن مبدأ
تحقيقات الطب الشرعي في شيرين
ابو عقل تظهر والنتيجة كانت
الاسلحة والمساعدات الى
اوكرانيا؟ بايدن يورط امريكا في
تحذيرات روسيا من رد لا يحمد
عقباه على الاتفاقات العسكرية
اوكرانيا يصدم العالم من النتيجة
وسط اجماع امريكي على تواصل تدفق
والصين تحذر لا تلعب بالنار
بايدن يثير الجدل بالامام
المخفي، فهل كان يقصد المهدي
تصويت للامريكيين بخصوص حرب
لحظاتها الاخيرة. اتفاق خطير.
السويد تستبق حسم انضمامها
حلولا للشمال فهل هو مدرك مع من
يتخاطب؟ مناكفات امريكية صينية
حرب مع روسيا وانغاريا تحذر من
قنبلة ذرية ستدمر اقتصادها.
جديد لجارته الجنوبية ليحذر من
وضع صعب في الجزيرة الكورية ويضع
والمجنون يعلن حالة الطوارئ في
كوريا الشمالية بينما يصعد رئيس
العالم على صفيح ساخن. فهل تندلع
الحرب العالمية الثالثة يا سادة?
اتفاقية دفاع مشترك قد تكون سببا
في الحرب العالمية الثالثة